APPRECIATE LETTING US KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE SEEING ON THE GROUND.
AS FLORIDA STRUGGLES TO RECOVER,
THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE IS
STRUGGLING WITH MESSAGING FROM
ONE OF ITS OWN.
YESTERDAY VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS
SEEMED TO SUGGEST RECOVERY
EFFORTS FROM HURRICANE IAN
SHOULD BE BASED ON EQUITY.
>> IT'S OUR LOWEST INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR MOST IMPACTED BY EXTREME
CONDITIONS AND IMPACTED BY
ISSUES NOT OF THEIR OWN
MAKING -- ABSOLUTELY.
WE HAVE TO ADDRESS THIS IN A WAY
THAT'S ABOUT GIVING RESOURCES
BASED ON EQUITY, UNDERSTANDING
WE FIGHT FOR EQUALITY BUT ALSO
NEED TO FIGHT FOR EQUITY.
>> IF YOU THOUGHT THAT WAS
STRANGE, SHE'S MADE A STRING OF
COMMENTS LATELY THAT ARE DOING
HER ANY FAVORS.
>> YOU NEED TO GET TO GO AND GET
TO WHERE YOU NEED TO GO --
>> I DO BELIEVE WE SHOULD HAVE
RIGHTLY BELIEVED BUT CERTAINLY
BELIEVED THEY ARE SETTLED AND
THAT'S WHY I BELIEVE WE ARE
LIVING IN REAL UNSETTLED TIMES.
>> SO THE UNITED STATES SHARES A
VERY IMPORTANT RELATIONSHIP
WHICH IS AN ALLIANCE WITH A
REPUBLICAN NORTH KOREA.
>> THAT'S NEWS.
SHE WENT ON TO TALK ABOUT VENN
DIAGRAMS ABOUT A MINUTE BUT HER
GUESTS HAVE PROMPTED VOICES THAT
ARE TYPICALLY FRIENDLY TO THE
REST SUGGESTING NOW MAYBE SHE
SHOULDN'T BE ON THE TICKET IN
2024.
>> ONCE YOU HAVE THE REAL ESTATE
AND THE WHITE HOUSE IN YOUR
OFFICE IS THE OVAL, I DON'T
THINK YOU'VE GIVEN UP, IT'S HARD
TO TAKE THE NOMINATION AWAY.
WHAT I COULD SEE IS REPLACING
THE VICE PRESIDENT --
[APPLAUSE]
IT'S VERY POPULAR AND DIDN'T
SEEM TO WORK OUT AND I DON'T
KNOW, IT'S BEEN DONE BEFORE, I
THINK SHE'S A BAD POLITICIAN.
>> ALL RIGHT, A LOT TO UNPACK
HERE BUT WHAT'S START WITH THE
EQUITY COMMENTS.
SHE'S WRONG FIRST OF ALL.
ROBERT RESPONSE GOVERNOR FOR
DESANTIS, GIVING UP ASSISTANCE
BUT HURRICANES DON'T
DISCRIMINATE SO WHY SHOULD FEMA?
>> YOUR BASICALLY CALLING
BIRTHING PERSON MAJOR A RACIST,
THIS IS IDIOTIC BUT THAT'S WHY
IF HE NOTICED THE CROWD THAT
APPLAUD, THIS ISN'T REALLY NEWS
ON THE LEFT.
THEY DIDN'T LIKE HER WHEN SHE
RAN FOR PRESIDENT AND IF YOU
REMEMBER SHE DROPPED OUT BEFORE
THE PRIMARIES WHICH IS
EQUIVALENT OF PASSING OUT DRUNK
NEW YEAR'S EVE BEFORE THE BALL
DROPS AT MIDNIGHT.
SHE WAS THE ONE IN THE BATHTUB
AT 9:30 P.M.
SHE'S A TERRIBLE POLITICIAN AND
AN EMBARRASSMENT TO THE COUNTRY.
WHEN YOU GO TO THE TMZ, YOU HAVE
ONE JOB, YOU ARE THERE TO
DEMONSTRATE SOLIDARITY WITH
SOUTH KOREA.
ESSENTIALLY SHE SHOWED UP TO
YANKEE STADIUM AND STARTED LET'S
GO RED SOX CHANT AND EVERYBODY
IS ANGRY AND THE SHOULD BE.
>> WITH THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
IS SAYING IS THEY WANT
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON RACE,
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE CALLING
FOR.
>> THE COMMENTS WERE ODD AND
OFFENSIVE TO PEOPLE BECAUSE
PEOPLE NEED BASIC RESOURCES,
WATER AND FOOD, THEY DON'T HAVE
POWER.
TO SUGGEST THAT SOMEBODY SHOULD
GET THE HELP FIRST BECAUSE OF
THE COLOR OF THEIR SKIN IS
OFFENSIVE TO A LOT OF PEOPLE AND
COMMENTS ARE NOT HELPFUL AND
SOMEONE FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
SHOULD TALK TO HER ABOUT THE
COMMENTS.
>> ONE THING I THINK IS SORT OF
FUNNY, THERE'S A MESSAGE SHE'S A
LIABILITY BUT YOU ALSO --
[LAUGHTER]
>> WHERE WAS BILL MAHER WHEN
THIS WAS UP?
HE SHOULD HAVE MENTIONED THIS IN
2020, A LITTLE LATE NOW BUT THIS
IS JOE BIDEN'S JOB SECURITY.
SHE'S NOT GOING ANYWHERE AS LONG
AS KAMALA HARRIS STATES, JOE
BIDEN HAS A JOB BECAUSE AS BAD
AS SHE IS, THE WOMAN IS ALWAYS
WORSE.
WORSE THAN HARVEY WEINSTEIN AT
THIS TIME, SHE CAN'T HOLD ON TO
ANYONE.
EVERY SPEECH SOUNDS LIKE DR.
SEUSS WITH A STROKE, SAME WORD
OVER AND OVER, YOU DON'T KNOW
WHERE IT'S GOING.
I THINK WE HAVE A REAL CRISIS
WHEN IN THE MIDST OF A NATIONAL
TRAGEDY WE ARE USING RACE TO
DIVIDE PEOPLE AND POLITICS AT A
TIME WHEN THESE PEOPLE ARE
DIGGING OUT OF THEIR HOMES
TRYING TO RESCUE FAMILY AND
PETS.
IT'S THE LAST THING SHE SHOULD
BE DOING, SHE SHOULD JUST STAY
HOME AND BE QUIET.
>> SHE DIDN'T MAKE IT TO THE
IOWA CAUCUSES, THE FIRST --
>> EVEN IN CALIFORNIA SHE WAS
LIKE FISH OR SOMETHING.
>> SHE WASN'T POPULAR BEFORE
THIS WHOLE THING BEGAN.
>> THE ONLY THINK I'LL GIVE HER
POINTS FOR IS AT LEAST WE HAVE A
MEMBER TALKING TO LIVING PEOPLE.
[LAUGHTER]
THEY ARE NOT GOOD COMMENTS BUT
AT LEAST THE PEOPLE ARE ALIVE.
>> DO THEY KEEP HER AROUND OR --
>> I THINK THEY WOULD LIKE TO
GET RID OF HER.
I HEAR THIS FROM ERRATIC
FRIENDS, THEY SEE THE SAME
POLLING WE SEE, SHE'S DRIFTING.
SHE WAS IN SINGLE DIGITS HER
LAST RUN.
SHE'S NOT EVEN POPULAR IN HER
OWN PARTY OR STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SO THAT'S WHY, THEY NEED TO GET
RID OF HER BUT AT WHAT COST AND
WHO DO YOU PUT IN?
IF YOU PUT GAVIN NEWSOM IN, OR
BIDEN LOOKS LIKE A GATEKEEPER,
THEY NEED TO GET RID OF HIM.
>> THEY KNEW THIS WHEN THEY
PICTURE, SHE COULDN'T MAKE IT TO
THE IOWA CAUCUSES AND WAS
PULLING HER OWN STATE WHERE
SHE'D BEEN ELECTED STATEWIDE AND
THEY KNEW THIS.
>> THEY DID AND THEY KNEW SHE
WASN'T POPULAR THEIR BASE BUT
PERHAPS THEY THOUGHT THEY NEEDED
A WOMAN AND A WOMAN OF COLOR.
>> BILL MAHER MADE IMPORTANT
POINTS, IDENTITY POLITICS HAS TO
TAKE A BACKSEAT TO COMPETENCY
AND HE'S RIGHT.
IT'S SO IMPORTANT AND AMAZING TO
SEE BOTH SIDES.
>> I WANTED TO SAY FLORIDA IS
NOW MY ADOPTED STATE SO MY
PRAYERS ARE WITH MY LOW
FLORIDIANS, GOVERNOR DESANTIS
HAS DONE AN INCREDIBLE JOB.
FLORIDA DISASTER FUND.ORG TO
DONATE, I THINK